aber das wird kommen meine damen und
herren herzlich willkommen hier heute zu
einem neuen video ads bereich und hätte
eine wette und ihr seht es auch für
rechtswidrig hält
[Musik]
eine kapsel mit einer aufgabe drauf du
suchst ist super wir haben hier drei
grad verkaufen allerdings eigentlich
noch einen leeren eine deutschlandkarte
ausgedruckt und die auch vier din a4 ist
jetzt gepackt
wir haben hier alle möglichen
bundesländer mit dabei die beiden sind
bayern und in nordrhein-westfalen
niedersachsen mehr kenne ich nicht
berlin brandenburg sachsen anhalt einen
landfall ist deutschland damit
mittlerweile auch schon auf jeden fall
mit jedem bundesland eine challenge
zugeordnet beispielsweise hier unten das
größte bundesland flächenmäßig gewinne
deutschland ist ja bayern dasteht
selbst derjenige der mit dem dach
möglich ist muss den bürgerbus bringen
dass sie die aber die haben wir
beispielsweise eine socke in einem
wassereimer das heißt derjenige der
dieses bundesland hier trifft muss mit
der zocker im wasser der muss in eine
von 14 trägt und musste dann das ganze
video mitternacht zu ende allerdings
auch nicht nur schlechte challenges
sondern auch gute sachen die man machen
darf um zwei wären daran den schoko von
essen hier sieht man massiert und hier
beispielsweise 10 euro von denen
gegenüber geschenkt wenn man allerdings
noch zwei mehr oder weniger sonder
felder und zwar einerseits haben wir das
soccerfeld schleswig holstein das heißt
wenn man darauf trifft darf man sich
aussuchen hängen möchte ich das wirklich
machen oder möchte ich meinen job
einlösen und da muss man eine schlechte
kindheit nicht machen und weil derlei
stadt bundesland bremen hamburg und
berlin die haben die komplett schwarz
gemacht weil da passiert gar nichts wenn
man die trifft dann ist einfach der
andere wieder ein so wichtiger dass
ribery dann auf jeden fall aussehen die
schule beziehen wer sich wehren wir uns
auf diesen stuhl setzen schon eine linie
das ist die ellbogen linie weil es
eigentlich als ellenbogen danach mit dem
ellbogen nicht über diese linie
hinausgehen das heißt es jetzt gerade
ist ist das beste was du vorgehen dürfte
es aber wenn wir weiter nach vorne
gelungen das wäre nicht mehr erlaubt
weil dann will man und ich haben jetzt
beide jeweils sechs würfe und wenn ein
feld getroffen wieder auf der karte dann
fällt ist weg also wenn einmal zehn euro
getroffen wird dann ist es durch
gestrichen wenn der nächste 10 euro
trifft dann muss er noch mal werfen bei
zeit schon getroffen wurde
das ist genau die gerinnsel als jude hat
hier ganz knapp das telefon getroffen
das heißt sie müssen nun sandra noten
wollen von uns google muss der sandra
sagen dass sie ganz ganz doll durchfall
hat ponys dann mal schauen was anderes
sagt und wie sie jude weiterhilft bei
ihrem was ein paar sekunden später
ich habe total vergessen dass andere
wahrscheinlich gerade noch in der schule
ist deswegen nimmt julia sprachnachricht
für sie auch durchfall als nur wasser
wenn ich weiß echt nicht was ich machen
soll sondern als antwort schneide ich
euch jetzt im schnitt mal rein
die gehälter steckt in der kartoffel in
deiner stadt musste gar nicht mehr
scheiße malta
das telefon sprechen jetzt tue ich denn
das gute entscheidung getroffen damit
das format schrift dann muss man einfach
normal werfen die sache mit dem
ellenbogen bis auf diese meldungen
deshalb lag der hase
nein nein
dieser habe ich nur diese fremdscham
sollte berlin fällt nun sogar jetzt eine
einkehr ins ganz deutlich machen dass
ich mir aussuchen was machen muss
leute ich würde mich echt mega freuen
wenn ihr beim vorteile creator kathrin
zeit nehmen würde
hektisch junis weiter von ihrem sechs
würfen meine damen und herren es geht
los auf wie viel spaß supermacht klasse
danke allen die auf der straße oder den
beruf geworden war danke dafür könnte
ich mir schon vorstellen so als
reinigungskraft müll rausbringen so tier
mensch die sache bisher felder wechseln
die alle etwa im mittigen unteren
breiten sich weiter nach oben
ihr seht schon leute und nun an habe ich
einen filter in meiner fresse user ich
hatte gehofft das wird es nicht treffen
oder zu ende das wird jetzt so viel
arbeit im schnitt kann man ja auch man
da lassen dann jetzt oder hey 5000
naja bundes dritten abfuhr für meine
lieben freunde bisher haben wir nur
negative sachen getroffen
allerdings wird sich das er nun
vielleicht ändern mit der kompletten
eben dass wir bisher nur negatives an
mein gott jetzt habe ich wieder den
wilden filtern sich um einen krieg
das ist das ist sau klaus also ich hab
nur den joker getroffen
das heißt das nächste mal wenn ich etwas
negatives treffe kann ich mir selbst
überlegen haye will ich das wirklich
machen oder lass ich es einfach komplett
verpuffen wer abends ganz spontan dazu
entschlossen dass wir sagen dass jeder
nur fünf würfe hat weil er vergessen
haben dass wir die stadt bundesländer
raus gelassen haben und es somit sonst
keine ansporn mehr gegeben hätte was
gutes zu treffen
du bist
ja geil
das problem ist er komplett ins wasser
gegangen und musste später wurde der
dritte versuch folgen je mal schauen ob
dies weil ein bundesland trifft
[Musik]
neben nicht hinter mir und erzählte von
jule der sekte versucht mittlerweile
hinter den sitzen als zweiter versuch
von jule wurm und nicht gut voran wie
ich damals
der neue ideen verlor und jetzt
versuchen dabei irgendwann sind wir hier
einfach nur nein wer das jetzt werden
zunächst 30 ist das mittlerweile würden
habe ich ja schon wie ihr seht das 157
er ist ganz klar unter schock und werde
teilweise versucht freundlich über die
mittlerweile schon neue taktik mit dem
da verhält und wie auf 1500 mal bissig
auf gut ski komme vorletzte wo vom
vorteil von rotenburg ich treffe jetzt
massage oder gucci hier komm ich würde
machte mir nicht von allein
[Musik]
wenn man widerstehen quantitativ mit dem
mito und er hat ja auch wissen wie ein
fernes aufhören judes letzter wurf es
gibt nur noch eine gute sache dass dies
gut ski auf der rechten seite darf man
sich was bei uci aussuchen für in einem
angemessenen rahmen
bester wurf schauen dass sie treffen
wird
der regen war ich habe mich hat gefreut
aber trocken liegestützen scheiße echt
nicht mehr
das ist voll peinlich jude erstellt und
die jung glaube ich schaffe es nicht
einfach runter zu gehen ist ein
doppelpack alle in die kommentare
dass der beschrittene sportler der welt
mein letzter wurf meine damen und herren
es gibt nur noch negative sagte es sei
von hier so aus als wäre das gut gewesen
das ganze von hierfür ist die zeit ein
bisschen sonst hätte man getroffen aber
nein ich muss bei der band ablecken
eigentlich waren zehn liegestützen
angedacht schule hat 0,3 liegestützen
gemacht sondern er denke ich auch keine
komplette band jetzt hat sondern den
türrahmen weil ich habe schon öfters mal
was abgelegt in videos und dabei habe
ich vier stunden angekommen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
also boten und kloaken damals war auf
jeden fall schlimmer abend meine lieben
freunde wenn es euch gefallen dass er
das gerne einen daumenbruch bei diesem
video hier da schreibt uns gerne in die
kommentare das ganz normal machen sollen
vielleicht mit einer europakarte oder
eine armee die karte und dann nicht mit
aufgaben sondern mit shops und einkauf
muss oder dinge die man essen muss mein
letzter verein auf jeden fall auf das
feld lecken hier in hamburg das brandgut
ski die socke und selbst sind übrig
geblieben die drei statt bundesländer
wie bereits gesagt war anja joker das
hat keiner von uns getroffen und jetzt
kommen aber auch das auto
[Musik]